this is a chart published by the world
economic forum in 2016.
it's a chart that crystallized a
conversation that had been circling for
quite some time
about this notion of the fourth
industrial revolution
what the world economic forum did in
2016 was give that conversation form
and structure what they also did was
give the fourth industrial revolution a
backstory
they made it part of a series of earlier
waves of
history and waves of economic and
technical transformation
of course in doing that they also
stabilized both that history and the
context and consequences of that history
they
also made a fetish of the technical
systems and in some ways made quite
mysterious what the consequences of
those transformations had been to human
society
to culture and in some ways what's also
missing from this story is the story of
who made that possible and both
individual biographies and the kind of
practices
and practitioners that had to develop so
what would happen if you
revisit all these revolutions with an
eye to two questions
what did it take to get to scale in each
one of those moments and what did scale
look like
and the reason for asking those
questions of the first three industrial
revolutions is to help position
ourselves to think more critically about
this fourth one